voilà madame le ministre vous êtes donc
avec nous d'abord il y a parfois une
petite confusion il ne s'agit pas de
confondre avec les allocations
familiales il y a les allocations
familiales et il y a le complément
familial deux chos différ bien sûr les
allocations familiales qui sont versées
à toutes les familles sans plafond de
ressources ne sont absolument pas touché
le complément familial se substitue à
comme il vous l'avz indiqué tout à
l'heure à C prestation qui était
actuellement versé sous condition de
ressources et alors maintenant il y aura
une seule prestation ce qui permettra
une très grande simplification d'un
montant unique de 340 francs alors
pourquoi cela marche pour euh les
familles qui ont un enfant de moins de 3
ans pour celles qui ont euh trois
enfants et pour celles qui ont deux
enfants rien du tout i c'està dire que
jusqu'à maintenant il y avait un assez
grand éparpillement entre les familles
et euh un plafond de ressource en
général assez bas et nous avons estimé
qu'au fond les familles qui avaient un
enfant de moins de 3 ans avaient des
difficultés particulières des frais
particulier du fait que ou bien la mère
cesse de travailler parce qu'elle doit
s'occuper de son enfant et alors il n'y
a qu'un salaire ou bien si la mère
travaille avec un jeune enfant il doit
être à la crèche il n'est pas encore en
maternelle ou il est confié à une
nourrice et les frais de gardes sont
très élevés alors il y avait
actuellement une allocation de frais de
garde mais qui était versée dans des
conditions très compliquées maintenant
automatiquement dès que la mère a un
enfant de moins de 3 ans elle touchera
cette prestation bien sûr avec un
certain plafond de ressources mais
suffisamment élevé pour que 70 % des
familles le touchent Madame le Ministre
on a dit on commence à dire qu'il s'agit
du une politique d'assistance pas d'une
véritable politique de la famille on na
pas tellement envie d'avoir des enfants
en entendant ce genre de de petites
mesures un peu ponctuelle oui alors ce
ne sont pas du tout des mesures
ponctuelles elles touchent plus de 2
millions de familles et parmi les
familles qui se trouvent dans cette
situation d'avoir un enfant de moins de
3 ans ou trois enfants et plus ce sont
80 % des familles qui seront touchées ça
n'est donc pas du tout de l'assistance
il n'y a pas moins de il n'y a pas 80 %
des familles qui relèvent de
l'assistance ce qu'on peut dire ce sont
simplement que que les familles qui ont
les revenus les plus élevés ne
bénéficient pas de cette famill et je
crois que tous les Français trouveront
tout à fait équitable que dans une
perspective de réduction des inégalités
les prestations soient réservées selon
un certain montant de platformme de d'un
certain montant de ressources et surtout
comp tenu du fait que sur le plan de la
fiscalité c'est ce qui a été exposé
longuement cet après-midi à l'Assemblée
les prestations familiales actuellement
ne sont pas imposées et que la fiscalité
profite aux fam
les plus aisés alors justement tout à
l'heure à l'Assemblée t tous les bans de
l'Assemblée opposition et majorité
confondu réclamer le le déplafonnement
complet pourquoi est-ce que vous n'avez
pas pu accorder parce que le l'ensemble
des parlementaires des députés demandait
le déplafonnement qui coûte une somme
très importante 3 milillards 400
millions pour qui serait destiné à ces
20 % de familles les plus favorisées ce
qui est donc une somme très importante
et demandait qu'en contrepartie euh les
prestations familiales soient imposées
alors tout d'abord l'imposition ne
rapportait qu'une partie de cette somme
environ la moitié et de toute façon on
aurait abouti à une situation si on
avait pas revu les barines fiscaux ce
qui est très compliqué très difficile
qui doit donner lieu à des études
minutieuses avant de le faire on aurait
abouti en l'état à ce que en définitive
ce soit les revenus moyens qui soient
imposés et qui payent des impôts sur ce
complément familial donc touche moins au
profit de ces 20 % de familles dans les
classes supérieures qui auraient touché
qui auraient aussi payer des impôts mais
tout de même auquel il aurait il serait
resté une partie de ce complément
familial et sur le plan d'équité
vraiment ça nous apparaissait pas
justifié en l'état si on veut faire ce
genre de réforme il faut les étudier
sérieusement longuement en faisant des
études très précises je vous laisse
madame car vous devez revenir à
l'Assemblée retourner à l'Assemblée pour
parler d'un texte de l'origine du RPR
cette fois de Claude Labé sur la
retraite à 60 ans pendant ce temps